so what I'm gonna do here is we're just
going to be going to simple rectangle
and we're looking about the fact that
we're looking at a shape like this and
we're not just measuring a single theme
when you combine these measurements in
different ways it introduces some new
and interesting problems for us which we
consult okay so let's just suppose that
this rectangle is 6 centimeters by 8
centimeters okay and now that we're in
like we're in a world now which
comprehends the fact that this area here
before like when you met this in u7 you
just kind of shoot
oh it says 6 centimeters it must be
exactly 6 centimeters but you guys
though just because I say 6 centimeters
there if I measured it out it might not
be six series what else could it be
could you tell me the upper and lower
limits like that measurement yeah it
could be 5.5 or it could be 6 by 5 right
you've got just by seeing this six
enemies there and they don't tell you
anything else you know that this an
error sort of baked into this
measurement in the same way that 8
centimeters they're not necessarily a it
could be yeah 7 point 5 centimeters okay
well it might be but if you can really
be that accurate if you've got a more
accurate varies but you can say a point
zero centimeters right and then it's
like Oh someone's measured to the
nearest millimeter right but at the
moment I don't know probably more
announcer than you want okay now now
that I've noted this down I'm just gonna
ask two simple questions on this
questions which you would have answered
before in simple terms but now I want to
think about error so my two questions
are perimeter and area so that's awesome
so on the face of it like if I told you
it was rectangle it was six and eight on
those measurements what would you tell
me the perimeter actually is I'm not a
trick question you've got two 6s which
at 12 to 8 which is 16 12 plus 16 28 so
I'm gonna go here and I'm gonna write
that down okay that's what says the
primaries however I actually know that
there is range in there and when I said
6 plus 6 might not have been 6 plus 6
it could be any number in this whole
range that could have been the actual
measurement I did it once twice three
times four measurements have gone into
this perimeter all right now remember
you told me the greatest possible error
the absolute error was half a centimeter
every single time okay so if I say
what's the minimum perimeter that I
possibly could have measured right each
time I measure up in this four times
right I could be half a centimeter too
small do you agree with that so what's
the shortest the actual program of
anything's yeah instead of 28 it could
have been 26 right every time I measured
it it could have been half a centimeter
stronger than really was okay you might
say hey you only mentioned actually
twice well but I doubled those
measurements right so I'm using the
arrow and I'm using it three times in
exactly the same way I can say the
maximum further it's gonna be yeah I
could have under measured and really
it's two centimeters longer than what I
thought okay so I've got a perimeter
I know that the minimum and the maximum
so I did now say here therefore the the
absolute error in total for the entire
program if it started 228 and you could
have gone down to 26 or up to 30 what's
the difference that you have to go both
ways from that little distance
it's to your sometimes see some tech
books that say plus or minus two
centimeters oh and I'm just writing to
7bz
it doesn't actually matter why doesn't
it matter whether you put plus or minus
there or just say yeah that's right it's
about the size right just by saying the
word era that kind of implies yeah you
could go down you could go up that's
what arabes I don't know okay so I'm
just flagging it for you sometimes the
textbook will say well sometimes even
HSC exams it depends on like I don't
know what the weather was like that day
literally that you can just flip back
and forth between st. plus or minus or
not any possible okay so all that said
now that was primitive listening that
area now because area we had a calculate
area but this introduction of thinking
about error makes things more
interesting okay sir again simple
questions as if the six really was six
in the yen really was a what is the area
but now again I can think about if my
patients enrolled right what is the
smallest the area actually could have
been well you told me the smallest is
could be was five point five and this
was this could have been is seven point
five so these are the actual
measurements
well someone reached for their
calculator faster means time forty-one
your cloud I'm actually going to write
the working for this one so that you see
where my numbers came from so that when
you look back at this the forty one
point two five doesn't just leap out of
there where what it represents is when
you take all of the areas into account
and notice when you're calculating a
primadonna you use four areas right one
two three four but when you do the area
how many times is the error come in only
twice right because this perimeter is
really four numbers being added together
whereas an area is two numbers being
multiplied
I have a bit of it that's why got
nothing okay again I have these limits
already written down so the biggest the
area possible convenor is 6.5 by 8.5
some about another fifty five point two
five now interestingly we had up it
didn't look too bad before it's like 1
plus or minus 2 centimeters no big deal
but suddenly here this range starts to
get huge what is that why is it range so
much bigger than the bottom yeah you
multiplied numbers right so if you
introduce the little error when you
start multiplying that out it the effect
compounds so now if I ask this last
question this one is a bit tricky right
remember what I'm trying to ask is
what's the biggest I could possibly be
from what I think the premiere is or
what I think the area is okay what's the
difference you'd have to write this down
but what's the difference between the
area I think it is and the 6 my cell
phone I can just keep that number in
your head that's the smallest I could go
there what about the dudes in this
number and this number advancing them
yes not the same that's kind of funny
here you measure the difference between
these two and these two and the
difference is the same right so 28 is
smack bang in the middle but here it's
not it has to do with multiplication
when you multiply numbers you don't get
doc just neatly in the in the midpoint
okay so remember you told me what was it
six point something for this Simone six
point seven five and so the point she
finds out mean you're talking now what
I'm looking for is what's the biggest
the farthest I could possibly be and
therefore the biggest is the biggest not
one right now is the largest that would
possibly be away if I set this other
number six point seven five it's like no
no wrong it could be you could be
further away from that right because
this measure is clearly more than six
point seven five away from my
okay so this is a little bit funny
because it's not exactly the same in
both cases but that's what happens when
you do carry out and if you do all you
the effectively even more significant
because the error is compounded does
anyone have any questions in in most and
most test environments the most intense
environment and this is why I sort of
make me sound like this after the
question we can't give these three like
three parts right they'll say just tell
me what it is as measured tell me what
the upper and lower limits of the actual
perimeter for upper and lower limits of
the area are so you have to provide both
of those and then told me so that's
actually pretty fun right so in most
cases you don't give me the choice but
as your notice it's like you know the
bigger one is really always gonna be the
important one because that's where the
air starts to run away from you so just
to review thinking about percentage
error absolute area in terms of
measurement and then think about when
you combine things just be slower and
think about how these end up sort of
coming together
I didn't compare what you've actually
thinking it is versus how far away you
could be okay